you know the game win Los or Draw yeah
all right uh Trump I think no doubt was
the winner of the first debate in
Milwaukee he didn't even show up winner
he went he was on the he did this thing
with Tucker we saw the big purple line
that Pat and Rob showed us he crushed it
he was the winner last night it was a
draw he didn't win last night the
ratings show it but he didn't lose he's
still the guy he's still the top of the
polls but hear me out if Trump doesn't
come to the Miami debate in Florida he's
up the street in Mar Lago he's going to
take an L because there's only going to
be four guys on stage there it's going
to be Des santis it's gonna be Nikki
Haley uh it'll likely be it'll be VC
yeah and it may or may not be Christie
and Christy was hurling insults about
him his whole Donald Duck joke uh they
were basically saying who should you
vote off the island Chris Christie uh
sort of said he haphazardly didn't want
to respond and then they wrote and
finally like what'd you write down he
goes Trump yeah get Trump off the island
the the santz called him out Nikki
called him out Christy called him out
they're all getting a little more
comfortable calling Trump out because
he's not showing up for the debates now
why would he I when you're this high up
I get it but not in the Miami debate and
by the way on that point on Adam's exact
point which campaign organization came
out today that said what we saw last
night was so
discombobulated I don't think it's we
need a third debate at all there
shouldn't even be a third debate who
position paper was that the Trump
surrogates rout with that at 9:00 this
morning we don't think there should be a
third debate to your to your point well
there's going to be a third debate in
Miami it's already been announced oh of
course but what but why are they saying
it it's kind of what you said I don't
think think Trump's going to lose his
lead and I don't think he's in a danger
of dropping below 90% probability of
getting a nomination but I do think that
what could happen in the next two weeks
is that Haley and danis can flip and
remember she is right there with him in
New Hampshire right now Haley is right
there on the New Hampshire primary if it
was held right now it would be neck and
neck her into sis and she's gaining
momentum when is the Iowa primary when
is the new hsh iow caucus in the New
Hampshire primary Rob can you go the
calendar cuz that's what it comes down
to Trump's obviously crushing in the
National polls but I think it's I think
it's all about Valentine's Day Chris
Christie has a shot in New Hampshire Dan
santis has a shot in Iowa right so it's
not National polls it's each of these
caucus States or primary States January
15th Iowa I mean that's good listen Prem
Trump does show up in in Miami he said
last night he's not showing up to Miami
he's not he said that already yeah I
mean that would be that would be sick if
if he's up there cuz you know V is is
pro Trump trump will duck the here let
me send this to you rob Donald Duck is
that the chy call Donald he used the
word so Rob if you want to see the story
that I'm sending you uh Trump's not
going to show up to the third debate
even if it's in Miami Trump will duck
the third GOP debate even after previous
no shows got him Donald Duck nickname oh
gotcha he's not showing up that's what
they're do you think that's a smart move
Pat in Miami in November
yes really yes I mean look he has to
show up if those guys are super close
they're not close on anything correct
give me one person that's close
no by the way you want to know something
here's what the Santa said go go to
Twitter by the way go go to go to my
Twitter Rob if you can go to Twitter
this not the Santa said here's what nuum
said just go to Twitter and watch how he
describes what happened yesterday with
the debate Play Play that one right
there make it bigger and show okay
yeah watch this look what he says look
what he says back up a little press
plays Governor what do you think is
going to be the takeaway after this
debate from the American people watch
this I think it will be clear that Trump
comes out the dominant Force after this
debate I mean this is the
XFL oh my God and honestly I mean this
is maybe maybe a vice presidential
debate these guys are getting lapped by
Donald Trump it's not even close he not
even interesting he's right and I think
what's most interesting to me is do they
recognize that or are they actually
going to show up and run against the guy
that's in the way of their prospects to
be the nominee it's a zero sum game it's
a binary choice at the end of the day
it's not a rank Choice voting so either
these guys come after the front runner
and distinguish themselves or otherwise
they're wasting everybody's time and I
say this with love and respect there's a
reason some of the advertisings being
discounted for this debate people don't
even want to they know what a shot yeah
like even advertisers don't even want to
he's he's staying right Adam didn't me
and you say this how many months ago we
were the difference is he's not running
right now but he's staying ready Pat let
me let me ask you this I'm going to flip
it I'm going to flip it on on pbd not
that you've tooken a stance on this Joe
Biden's getting a lot of heat hiding in
the basement again you know RFK is out
there we're having Maryann Williamson on
tomorrow I believe I don't even know if
she's still running or not but RFK he's
out there he's at 15% let's say where
Biden's at 60% he's catching heat
basically you know not having
conversations not talking to the Press
pool not doing debates do the r do the
same rules apply if you're up 40 50
points in your own party I I don't think
Biden needs to show up to a debate I I
don't think Biden needs to the
Republicans can say whatever they want
he's not coming dude he's the president
look since SW doesn't in since when does
a sitting president come to debate I Tom
how has that ever happened since when
does a sitting president show up to a
democratic debate I can give you the
quick history here watch this no
incoming president has participated in a
primary debate since Ford Democrats want
to keep it that way yeah but Ford is
also not Biden because Ford became
president because somebody got uh he was
not elected no he wasn't
elected there was an Open Primary and
there was a lot of Ang these Republicans
that are like well he's got to show up
he doesn't president here he doesn't
he's he's become a president the rest of
you guys are trying to be a President
Biden is a president Trump is a
president now Trump was so unpopular
amongst Republican voters that he
doesn't have to sh like you you may lose
it yeah yeah like I remember one time in
one of the books I read that uh campaign
manager for Reagan Reagan wasn't really
hardcore campaigning on the second one
he thought it was going to be a slam
dunk and his man campaign manager says
Hey listen I know what you're doing you
got to kind of come and show show up you
got to go talk to people he can't be
hiding here and then he realized damn
this is actually something I got and
obviously he won dominantly but you got
to come up and do your thing
so and then yesterday I don't know if
you guys saw what New York did with
Trump you know what they're trying to do
to Trump marago okay Mar Lago if you
type in Trump New York Mar Lago this New
York judge is trying to say that marago
is worth somewhere between $18 to $26
million okay real estate Insider
bewildered by judges $18 million
valuation of Trump's maral Lago and I
tweeted yesterday I said if this thing
is $18 million I'm making a public cash
offer to buy this property okay that's
what I said yesterday believe if it is
okay so if you go lower and you you look
at this and you'll sell out the next day
and make half a billion dollars I would
make a half a billion dollars the next
day but here's what's going on over
there they're trying to get them to not
be able to work in New York by the way
this part's a little bit serious because
if they're able to lock up the money
that he can't spend his money that's all
they want to do but this is what this is
what third world countries do once they
lock up the rich man's money money that
he can no longer campaign on his own
what are you going to do where you going
to get the money from they're trying to
eliminate a candidate so flipping bad
it's not even funny so right now Palm
Beach there's a house on the market I
don't know if it's still on the market
or not for $250 million or $2 200
million it's not a it's not a big house
it's not as big I mean it's a big house
but it's not the size of a mar Lago
house and they're saying marago is worth
$18 million now a couple of the things
you know where they say well the house
he said it was 30,000 ft but it's really
10,000 whatever these other stories are
they have to address that those are
things that you have to address yeah but
to do it to the point where you want to
freeze their money so within 10 days
they have to do all this other stuff so
the the strategy of the left is to
eliminate the opponent immediately that
is the only way they see themselves not
getting Trump to win only way I'm
convinced again I'm so convinced they
are so scared because they think Trump's
going to win they're doing everything
and anything they can for for that guy
not to run anything and everything that
can isn't that like like we're not
stupid you're not the Public's not
stupid that's literally cheating you are
going after the the the number one guy
to try to get him in jail and take his
and like you're seeing it with this
judge they're all left like how is that
how was that legal how can you do that
yeah so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here h